les travaux viennent de débuter à la
gare d'orsay où sera installé le musée
du 19e siècle pour s'insérer entre le
louvre et le musée d'art moderne
ce musée du 19e siècle a été décidé il
ya deux ans en conseil interministériel
on a donc commencé la réfection du
bâtiment c'est la première fois qu'une
caméra de télévision peut pénétrer dans
ces locaux depuis ce matin la gare
d'orsay s'est mise à l'heure du 19e
siècle mais il faudra trois ans de
travaux avant que ne soit achevé ce
musée de l'art et de la civilisation du
siècle dernier le projet accepté
n'entraînera pas de grands changements
quant à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du
bâtiment qui est parfaitement
représentatif de l'architecturé de cette
époque j'aurais des travaux très
importants mais la structure va rester
dans l'état d'ailleurs le bâtiment est
entièrement protégé classé monument
historique donc ses grandes toiles ses
grands dernières seront de même que les
façades seront protégés maintenus se
porte même un problème en 1907 et contes
russes étaient très rapides il y avait à
l'époque énormément d'artisans vous
retrouver les mêmes conditions de
travail aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'avec l'informatique et toutes nos
techniques modernes ne va pas plus vite
et même plutôt plus lentement qu'en 1900
qui avait fallu 18 mois de chantier il
nous faudra deux ans et demi de travaux
le grand déménagement seront amorcés au
mois de mars avec le départ de la
compagnie renaud-barrault pour le palais
de glace en mai la salle des ventes
reviendra sur la rive droite dans un
hôtel drouot entièrement réaménagé et la
sncf continuera d'exploiter la gare du
sous-sol quant à l'hôtel fermé depuis 71
il sera restauré et accueillera des
expositions temporaires
pour le reste les architectes
utiliseront au maximum les immense
verrière du toit
les impressionnistes exige une lumière
naturelle et nous avons dans cette
grande galerie qui est la galerie des
auteurs environ 400 mètres carrés qui
seront consacrés aux impressionnistes
vous trouver quand même assez haut du
trou à la lumière va quand même pénétrer
à l'intérieur
à la lumière va pénétrer à l'intérieur
puisque le toit est déjà constituée par
une verrière
il y aura un certain nombre de petites
alvéoles tous les 5 mètres à l'intérieur
de cette galerie et l'ensemble des
tableaux qui sont actuellement au jeu de
paume viendra dans cette grande galerie
lorsqu'en 1983 des travaux seront
terminés le musée du 19e siècle offrira
24 mille mètres carrés de surface de
présentation où seront regroupées toutes
les oeuvres témoignant de cette époque
coût de l'opération 3 163 millions de
francs cet ensemble complétera entre le
louvre et le musée d'art moderne la
série de musées qui à paris retrace
l'histoire de l'art français du
moyen-âge à nos jours